[Música]
economía en directo américa de france 24
me acompaña en el estudio y martes
daniel hablando en danger a volví no
estaba muerto estaba de parranda como
vicente y volví yo también no estaba
muerta estaba estaba de parranda también
me dan y bueno hablemos entonces de
economía porque el gobierno de eeuu va a
poner a pagar a los más ricos como así
pues mire yo voy de empresa en todo el
proyecto de presupuesto ante el congreso
para el año fiscal 2000 23 esto por 579
billones de dólares millones de millones
un poco menos que el de este año pero
con un mayor gasto en defensa una de sus
fuentes de financiación es justamente el
alza del impuesto a los ricos ya las
corporaciones irá dirigido a hogares con
una riqueza de más de 100 millones de
dólares que tendrán que pagar un 20 por
ciento sobre sus ingresos o ganancias no
realizadas que son las ganancias no
realizadas lo que se valorice de una
inversión que todavía no se ha vendido
la casa blanca estima que unos 700
multimillonarios estarían sujetos al
gravamen y que recaudará más de 360
millones de dólares en una década
escuchemos al presidente
para la mayoría de los estadounidenses
de los últimos años fueron muy difíciles
y los llevaron al límite pero los
multimillonarios y las grandes
corporaciones se hicieron más ricos que
nunca en este momento los
multimillonarios pagan una tasa promedio
del 8 por ciento sobre sus ingresos
totales
si ganas mil millones de dólares es
fantástico solo paga lo que te
corresponde un bombero y un maestro
pagan más del doble de tasa impositiva
que un multimillonario
y eso no es justo estar fe eso no es
justo daniela y rusia amenaza con
suspender el suministro de gas pues
recordemos que esta es el arma más
poderosa que ha tenido este país la
dependencia que hay en europa de sus
hidrocarburos pues ahora con las
sanciones que le impiden incluso acceder
a sus reservas internacionales el
kremlin está buscando la forma de que
sus compradores de paguen pero en rublos
y advirtió que tomará medidas si los
países europeos a los que calificó de
hostiles se niegan a hacerlo el corte
del suministro tendría como efecto
principal desde luego a parte de un
posible racionamiento pues un aumento
aún más dramático en los precios de la
energía y es que raúl el poco gas que
pueden llevarles desde otros países es
más costoso y más difícil de transportar
los ministros del g7 calificaron la
medida de inaceptable consideran que
constituyó una violación de los
contratos vigentes con rusia y nos
venimos hasta el sur de américa porque
precisamos de los altos cargos meses
antes de las elecciones pues primero que
todo el lunes renunció el asediado
ministro de educación militó ribeiro en
medio de acusaciones sobre presuntos
cargos de corrupción y el segundo cambio
tiene que ver con petrobras el gigante
petrolero estatal su presidente joaquín
silva el 1 fue destituido por ya ir
bolsonaro quien de inmediato puso al
consultor energético y académico adriano
pires a consideración de la asamblea de
accionistas de abril como nuevo siguió
al mercado le sonó raro esta postulación
porque el mismo pérez ha sido criticado
varias veces por el mandatario también
fue postulado el presidente del club
flamengo como director ejecutivo fútbol
petroleum sí y como dicen que el dinero
enferma también ganan una cantidad de
dinero y aún así roban y quieren más y
más y más pero pues qué pasó qué razones
se dio el presidente para esta
sustitución volviendo a ese tema ni pues
mire lo curioso raúl de este tema y es
que la razón por la que se va al
presidente de petrobras sin siquiera
cumplir un año en el cargo es casi
idéntica al motivo que llevó a la
expulsión de su antecesor los precios de
los combustibles
a cercanas a bolsón arios dicen que está
muy irritado por la actual política de
precios que traslada a los consumidores
finales el incremento de las
cotizaciones internacionales del crudo a
principios de este mes la empresa los
aumentó en un 25 por ciento aduciendo
pues los efectos de la guerra lo que
también suena raro es que éstos antes de
elecciones entonces podría la gente
también culpar al presidente de la alta
inflación y él estaría también como
atemperando un poquitico esto y como
dicen por ahí la gasolina el alto precio
del combustible podría tumbar los
gobiernos mire que en venezuela eso sí
jamás se tocó vamos a ver los
indicadores a ni con excepciones de
shanghai que sigue a la baja por los
confinamientos las bolsas asiáticas
subieron en la jornada del martes de
manera generalizada lo mismo hacen las
europeas esperanzadas en lo que pueda
suceder en la nueva ronda de diálogos
entre rusia y ucrania la cifra del día
la tiene alentadora o lloramos lloremos
porque se está desarrollando la asamblea
anual del bid y dice que menos del 3 por
ciento va a crecer la con américa latina
y el caribe en 2023 debido a la crisis
perdón en 2022 este año debido a la
crisis en ucrania el año pasado había
crecido 7 por ciento bueno pues sí
complicado el orden mundial en este
momento gracias por toda la información
más adelante con más economía pasamos a
ver a vernos el reportaje